one game i got 49 points at the end of  three quarters we up by 30. i'm working  on my dribble moves i finger roll and  miss my father walks on the court in his  uniform looking sharp shoes shine call  the timeout damn we in the middle of the  game caller timeout yes sir so he takes  me outside what are you doing and you  know i'm a high school american so i'm  starting to feel myself get cool young  man i'm working on my doctor  smack in front everybody ain't no doctor  j b shack  so now  cause remember when you wear the drill  serge you're not allowed to cry but i'm  pissed  so now i said okay this is what you want  me to do so i just started dunking  that's why when i dunked i was trying to  kick and i was trying to tear the rim  down and then when i started doing that  i started seeing opponents go like